hey leute ich darf euch ganz herzlich zu
diesem video begrüßen es ist an der zeit
danke zu sagen
zwar habe ich vor kurzem die 400.000
ausgereift das war ein großer traum von
mir immer so als 400.000 akkus zu haben
war jeder mensch auf der welt weiß dass
mit 390.000 album einfach ein stück
scheiße bist niemals das jetzt für dich
möchte auf der straße liegen mädchen an
und dies bis zu 390 verpiss dich du
weißt aber jetzt habe ich die 400.000
das habe ich nur eine person zu
verdanken und das sich auch im titel
nämlich ohne scheiß leute ist so dumm
und marita über youtube okay es ist so
beschränkt sich ja mal an überlegt woran
gratis format zum beispiel ein paar luca
überlegt die krasse formate man versucht
richtige energie reinzustecken und es
läuft so ok ist was zu vollziehen dann
dringend bianca einige ein song man
macht ein video sieben minuten wo man
halb nackt da sitzt und mit den song
lästerte aufsicht uk youtube auf den
kopf zieht und den kanal geht so ab wie
noch nie zuvor
real aber jetzt ohne witz ich muss erst
mal danke sagen herr niebel wir diesen
song nicht gemacht wird mich hat immer
noch keine marge und herren alles gute
erstmal vergessen als ich holte auch
noch irgendwas war halt geschenk wieder
aufmachen
[Musik]
ein erster echter youtube ok läutet
marienplatz ein zu blocken damit ihr
versteht wie durch jetzt sage dass über
sagt also normalerweise hatte main kanal
so ins ganz okay uns gut wie zu 300.000
aufrufen 48 stunden okay jetzt habe ich
ein video baby gemacht 1,8 millionen in
80 stunden
danke baby normalerweise macht man kanal
anfangs so 304 oder abonnenten ich ein
video über die youtube alle 13.000
abonnenten an einem tag danke baby
normalerweise hatten wir von mir so 56
7000 leicht ich mach ein video baby
60.000 live danke die die entwickler
fucking absurd aber muss als pippi
danken klickt der surfer scheiße ja und
trommelfelle sind alle gelacht in ganz
deutschland was meine wohl die ganzen
bislang fährt ohne dass die erde drehen
alter wo willst du wirst noch tritt
teilweise wurde deutet die 1,4 millionen
6 war einfach leute die im trommelfell
geplatzt
viele am gelitten aber was das für ein
heim verursacht
wie wäre vielleicht gemacht damit glaubt
mir bewährt damit sich einige
hunderttausend euro gemacht aber ich
muss einfach danke sagen gebiet du hast
du hast mein leben gerettet menschen
reden wieder mit mir auf der straße
waren gestern mit familien unterwegs mit
mir geredet stimmt auch gestern acht
müttern im bett und überlegt warum reden
sie auf einmal mit mir drin besteht und
es leid ich wollte mal reinschalten die
dakar ist nämlich alle decken realtime
deine abonnenten und reden dann hat mit
dir nicht mit dir reden seit schon lange
luca so die nicht nur 3d politikers
ordnung hat die meiste zeit als du mit
mir die leute doch eine allgemeiner
gedanke dieser sache ist absurd ist das
okay dieses video 20 millionen
aufgefordert das ok und so viele andere
videos gehen einfach so krass ab einfach
nur bei den bezügen im db hat jetzt
schon platz neun in den weiß gedeckten
videos aller zeiten weltweit und des
videos zwei tage als dieser song hat
wirklich youtube auf den kopf gestellt
und es ist schon krass wie dort abgeht
es ist richtig krass wie die leute sich
so schlossen versammeln um baby zu
helfen oder sich daran wenig geändert
sondern einfach wirklich die musik und
das wieder gemacht hast ja also die
person an dagegen habe ich was gerade
das ist ja auch aufgelaufen geht nicht
persönlich die ihn bewegt weil die ja
auch wirklich nicht zu kennen aber nie
fertig und leute luca schon recht es
geht einfach darum dass das produkt an
sich
es kommt auch ein produkt palazzi seit
wann produziert der produkt palast
selbst wenn der 12
er kommt immer drauf hast du eigentlich
schon das video von der fragen von wie
gesehen nein die hatten über
hochgeladene ihn nicht sehen und wie hat
mega viele die auch gemacht während
unglaublich groß gemacht hat jetzt die
gitarristen sind alle die autos von wie
die sind aus meinen kanal gekommen jetzt
verstehe ich mein liebes kanal nicht
davor mega gut weiterlief okay weil so
und auch jetzt auf einmal los babys
kanal scheiße mit abos und meinem baby
im main kanal sind einfach so die
gegensätze auf youtube wie die idee
abonnieren abonnieren
okay leute maria dankeschön für die
vielen tausend abonnenten für die kraft
tritt
video immer noch relativ gut geleitet
und es kann ich gut
watching you tube